Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. This is going to be my Agents of SHIELD episode 15 video.
I'm just gonna go ahead and call it Agents of Hulk hands just because of the niceBruce Banner shoutout.
They kept teasing Fury's orders in all
the flashbacks. Wouldn't it be funny if like
part of Nick Fury's orders were to mention
an Avenger
in every single scene possible. We also
get to see Lucy Lawless again which was awesome.
It's only in flashback. I was kinda
hoping that they developed some
crazy secret plot that would bring her
back in present day but it looks like
that's not going to happen.
So here we go, let's talk about some fun stuff. Careful for spoilers from the episode in case you haven't
seen it yet, starting with top 5 moments.
Number 5: flashback to the creation of the real SHIELD.
They didn't fully explain what's on that ship
that they were trying to destroy.
It sounds like it was just really precious
information. They were supposed to
implant that chip
and destroy the server, then sink the ship. And if it wasn't clear from
Edward James Olmos' speech later in
the episode, the new
real SHIELD rules by committee, instead of having a single Director.
Really the most fun part all those
scenes were watching Lucy Lawless kick butt.
Every once in awhile she'll tease doing like
a Xena sequel of some sort.
Most a character she plays nowadays are
less action based.
Like when she was on Spartacus, she wasn't one of the gladiators. That would have been badass.
Onto number 4: Mockingbird and Mack try
to take down the base.
This is hardcore Winter Soldier-Black
Widow stuff. Lots of fun
any gave it us the really awesome May vs. Mockingbird fight,
like they're fighting over the last bits of pizza or something. As much as it
sucks that the team is finding itself,
it's actually bringing Fitz and Simmons back together. They said the name
Fitzsimmons, like they smash the names
together several times.
I heard Edward James Olmos, I'm just gonna call him that insteaf of Gonzales - Gonzales is his
name on the show -
I heard him and Coulson say the name
Fitzsimmons.
which I think is kinda funny. Like even the
opposing team thinks of those two people
as one person. If you've been really
bummed out that they've kinda been on
the outs,  I think this is what's gonna
bring back together
this all real SHIELD versus Coulson's SHIELD stuff. Onto number 3:
the Reader, or Gordon how do you wanna to think about him, tells Skye about her heritage.
Technically they haven't called him the Reader,
like officially he's not the Reader on
the show, from the comics, but
his powers are very similar to what the
Reader does. It's the same thing
on Arrow or The Flash. Typically they call characters with powers
by their real first names
instead by the aliases, although that will probably change over time.
He does a really good job of breaking down
the mechanics of her powers:
everything in the universe has a vibrational frequency, which is actually true,
Skye's just able to manipulate those
vibrations. Her playing with the water in the sink
is a good example of what her powers
might look like when they're finely tuned.
She'll be able to manipulate physical
objects on a really fine level,
or elements at least, natural elements.
Everybody let me know if you're big Last
Airbender Korra fan.
I feel like Skye is the next best thing
to a live-action Korra.
The other thing that's going on here is
he's totally trying to turn her against SHIELD,
not necessarily in a sinister way. I
think he is just
really mistrustful normal people, big
organization.
He would probably say the same thing
about HYDRA or any other big
organization that Skye'd been working with.
The Inhumans in the comics are very
insular society, they normal people
so, it really doesn't matter whether you're good or evil; it's just either you're an Inhuman or your'e not.
Moving on to number 2: Coulson escapes with the Toolbox and meets up with Hunter.
'Consider the contract signed, what's the
mission boss'. Here's what they have to do:
so they have to track down Skye, Coulson has to find
and help Skye and deal with the real SHIELD. And we're within a couple of weeks
of the crossover with Age of Ultron, so
the real question is how the
show's gonna to reconcile all those things.
If Coulson ends up being the one to go after Skye, finds out where these Inhumans are,
like tracks her down,
I'm interested to see how they react to him
having Kree blood inside him,
because technically he's not an Inhuman. I'm really interested to see who the big gvillain
ends up being the second half a season, like
is Whitehall gonna step out of the shadows and be like 'surprise,
I'm not really dead'. He has that crazy
healing factor so unless
someone emerges from the Inhumans
camp and ends up being the big villain,
someone we haven't met yet,
I think he'll come back because Edward James Olmos' character, they went a long way
to making him sympathetic.
That's what all those flashback scenes were for him. 'Fury gave us, orders we need to
take the ship down'.
Obviously he's reversed his position and he kinda hates Nick Fury right now, but
he still trying to do good thing, even if it's fitting into what will become Captain America: Civil War.
And finally my number 1, WTF moment: Skye accidentally uses powers,
automatically, ends up killing someone,
and then leaves with Gordon.
As much as it was like a
really cool spectacle, really cool effect sequence, a couple really important
things happen there,
you know one: Skye's put out about her
powers. Two: Bobbi probably changed her
mind remember, she was like
this is Skye, she's not like those enhanced HYDRA people, she's a good person.'
She probably thinks Skye is super dangerous now, in a way that she did before.
Think of it as like the extreme version of what Simmons is trying to do.
I think Simmons is trying to help Skye, even though she's trying to suppress who she really is,
bobby is probably gonna be like a hard
liner and be like 'nope, we need to lock
them up, they're too dangerous.'
That's really like what the real SHIELD sounds like they're going to be doing;
they wanna find the Inhumans,
so they can protect everyone from them.
And that just sounds like Captain American: Civil War right there, even though the
reason for Captain America: Civil War
will be much more complicated than that. I think the Inhumans would just be part of it.
That's actually where I think the TV
show's doing a really good job working
with the films.
It's painting a broader context so it's gonna like:  Captain America: Civil War is gonna be
Iron Man vs. Captain America. They both have competing ideologies,
but there's also all this other political stuff going on in the background.
So that's where the TV shows picking up
the slack. Since we're a year
away from Captain America's Civil War, just expect things in general to get worse
and wose with this Inhumans plot. Inhumans vs. humans,
real SHIELD vs Coulson's SHIELD, like what should we be doing.
Things will just slowly degrade until finally you have like Camp Captain America,
Camp Iron Man. Very clearly Tony Stark
would be like a 'real SHIELD' person
and Captain America would be like a 'Coulson person'. Here's my big question for
you guys though:
Age of Ultron's coming up. Do you think
that will see Skye on Age of Ultron using
her powers because
it seems like it would be a mistake to let her ride the bench if her powers are so
big and so .
There hasn't been any confirmation about
about a Skye cameo, but
think about it this way: the Inhumans base is somewhere in China
which isn't super far from Sokovia which is the country where
Age of Ultron is taking place. So it is possible, and I do think we'll get
some Unhumans references in Age of Ultron,
but the movie isn't about Inhumans so it'll be like a very, very small part of it.
There's still a couple episodes of Agents of SHIELD before we get
to Age of Ultron, so I think once we get a little bit closer, we'll have a better idea of what
the crossover's gonna look like.
There's a really good shot that Hawkeye could be the Avenger to come on Agents of SHIELD.
And yes a lot of people are talking about
Adrianne Palicki's character, Mockingbird, possibly
replacing Black Widow in the movies when
Scarlett Johansson doesn't doesn't want
to appear in Marvel films anymore.
They'll just like slowly integrate her into the
movies because her character plays a
very similar role to what the Black
Widow plays.
They have very similar abilities. I will say my favorite Easter Egg from the
episode was definitely like the had where she put her fist up to that.
For a minute I thought it could be Captain America's fist, that he had
like punched the wall,
but it was just like way too big for his. Later in the episode they kinda confirm that
when they said that Banner design the
house. So the Hulk and
Captain America had both stayed there. If you guys remember that show
'The Tomorrow People' on the CW,
actually one of those actors, one of the leads Luke,* I can't remember his last name                                                                        *Luke Mitchell
of the top of my head,
he's going to be a new Inhuman character so we'll see him whenever Skye
gets to that place.
We got a little teaser with Skye's dad whenever he was collecting all those
enhance people. Think of it as like a crazier version of that, people with like
really awesome special powers.
Visual effects can be kind of expensive so I'm not expecting it to be too
ridiculous on screen but
I think they'll have some fun with it. Just
look forward to Skye training montage
New episode of Agents of SHIELD next week, be sure to subscribe to get it.
What's gonna happen is that Arrow and The Flash will both be on break, so I'll have a little
bit more times, I'll try to do some more Marvel videos next week. So if you
have any request for movie videos or
anything like that, feel free to leave
them in the comments.
Since Daredevil is coming up, if you guys
haven't seen any of my Daredevil videos
you can click here to catch up. I just did Kingpin explainer a little while ago,
and you can click here to learn what's
going on with the Deadpool movie. They just
confirmed it's going to be rated R, so
I know everyone's really excited about
that. Thank you so much watching, let's all high-five,
I'll see you guys tomorrow.